[Music]
before I get into introducing Larry and
today's subject a couple of things I
want to say so you there was a
registration card that you feel all
filled up and want to remind if there's
a raffle for some pretty neat prizes at
the end of the lecture so hang around
for that if you don't have to run off to
violin or soccer or Fall Ball and want
to say that you know one of the reasons
that we do this is for you to you know
learn about you know Yale's
science at Yale and to learn about the
opportunities there are for for students
in the community to come to Yale and
many of you have the mistaken impression
that it's really expensive to go to Yale
just this last year our financial aid
office is change their policies such
that and if you're a single parent and
your income is under seventy-five
thousand if your child gets into Yale
it's free now that's not just that's not
just free tuition that's room and board
it's cheaper to send them to Yale than
to keep them at home
and that's true for families with
incomes upwards of 200,000 a year that
only you'll be guaranteed that only 10%
of the family income above that seventy
five thousand will have to go towards
that total term bill so even for them
it's cheaper than keeping a teenager at
home I had six I know much cheaper so
it's a real pleasure today to have
professor Larry Gladney
Larry he's going to tell you a little
bit about his background but it's born
in Mississippi went to school in East
st. Louis got a degree Northwestern yep
went to to Stanford and then ended up at
Penn as a postdoc and then just rose up
through their ranks became a full
professor and eventually the Dean of
science at Penn and we were lucky enough
to steal him away a couple of years ago
and bring him here and so it's with
great pleasure for me to introduce
professor Larry Gladney
[Applause]
morning everybody can you hear me can
you hear me okay all right well first of
all thanks to Professor zoom for
inviting me here thanks to all of you
for coming out to celebrate science on
Saturday not to scandalize anybody but
if I take off my shirt I have a March
for science t-shirt on underneath this
which is basically an expression of the
fact that in our society science has
become so important and yet so
marginalized in terms of how much time
and effort we spend thinking about what
it's added to our lives so what I want
to do today is to actually give you
about 50 minutes 45 minutes of talking
after all the great demonstrations
outside which I well remember doing many
Saturday's at Penn and in that talk what
I hope that you take away from this is
that there is so much more yet to be
done yet to be discovered that if you
are at any age no matter what it is from
15 to 95 there is still really exciting
science which is coming in the next 10
years which you can actually be a part
of this is through what's called citizen
science but whether you're a person who
is just simply interested in following
along over the Internet at home or
getting involved in the many projects
that take place at Yale science is
something that can be a part of your
life
and probably should if you're excited at
all by any of the ideas I'm going to
talk about today so to begin with I'm
supposed to say a little bit about my
background and I'm gonna spend basically
just one minute on that which is to say
that the path to becoming a physicist
varies tremendously so my story is not
at all typical as you might expect but
it's also the case that it's not typical
for pretty much anybody who's ever been
a graduate student or postdoctoral
scholar with me we all came to physics
in very different ways I happen to be
the kind of person for whom physics has
always been
right it was like a religious epiphany
for me to discover it at age 12 and I
had always been interested in it since
before I can remember and that's because
from the age of three or so my uncle
tells me I've said I wanted to be a
scientist but a scientist who was
interested in just two really important
questions for me and that is what are
the big questions that we can ask about
how the world works and if you get into
thinking about it just for a little bit
what you realize is that those two big
questions that have been around for at
least 2,500 years in our societies are
what is the world made of and what holds
it together all right and so from a very
early age I've been motivated but I
understand trying to understand what's
the answer to these questions now the
fact that it's mmm you know something
that you can be thinking about at age
three four five is not really so
relevant as the fact that we've had more
than twenty centuries of people trying
to understand how to answer those
questions and what we've come down to is
first of all we've identified the set of
people who are strange enough to be
spending most of their life thinking
about that which is the set of people
who are called physicists and the
science is called physics that's not
that other people and other disciplines
don't think about this it's been thought
about from the point of view of
philosophy it's been thought about from
the point of view of other branches of
science but it's the physicists to
actually have this on their t-shirt
stick and they're there if they're a
union card if you want that says that
these are the questions that we are
particularly responsible for trying to
figure out if we can get to an answer
that we believe the answer has to
however be in a form which scientists
will respect is something that we first
of all are able to reproducibly study
and that we're also able to explain in
three different ways all right so one
way is through math and equations
another way is through experiments that
is observations and then the third way
is to do what I'm
doing to you today which is to try and
explain it in common-sense language and
do that we have to rephrase the question
from the ones I asked up there they're
the same questions but we ask them in
languages which allow us to explain it
in those three different ways so what
are the fundamental constituents of
matter what are the fundamental forces
the reason we do that is that forces and
constituents are things that can be
observed in the laboratory we can see
what their actions are we can study them
and by virtue of reporting what those
observations are in common-sense
language and in terms of equations we
can actually do the mission or complete
the mission the problem is that these
are so hard that it's taken us really as
I said more than 20 centuries to even
come up with an approximation of what we
think is a believable answer so if we go
back to the beginning this was something
that has been thought about I said
probably more than 2500 years but at
least around 550 BC on a little island
port city called Meletis we do have
historical records that show that there
were five people who were really
thinking very intently about those two
questions and so just because its
historical I like to say what their
names are right so it's Thales of
Miletus aleksa Mandor Anaximander and
AXA manys whose portrait has actually
shown up there on the left
Democritus and his teacher
Lucifer's those five people now the
first three of those were really
concerned with the idea of how do you
ask the question so that you can answer
it in the three ways that I just talked
about right so they are the first people
to say that you have to be able to both
predict it with math you have to be able
to show it in observations and you have
to be able to explain it in plain
language those three are the people who
first said that's the standard by which
we understand that the questions either
can be answered or are answered by
anything that we've done in terms of our
studies the other two Democritus and
Lucifer's I'll come to and in just a
minute all right but annex amenties is
the person who you probably remember
most for what he sort of said the basic
elements are right earth water air and
fighter now in fact if you go into the
history what he actually said was that
everything is made of air so he was the
first person that we know there might
have been others but he's the first
person that we know actually decided
that air was something that could feel
different in observations and like water
could actually be different in terms of
how you touch it and interact with it
depending on what state it was in and
what I mean by that is water for example
can be a liquid but if you make it very
cold it becomes a solid if you make it
very hot it becomes a gas or steam and
so he was the first person to realize
and the observation that that was
something that could actually be true
for most things in the universe started
with him with a very simple observation
kind of unbelievable which is he blows
on his hand and he realizes that if his
mouth is open it feels warm and if your
mouth is closed it feels cool but it's
the same stuff right so how does it have
these two different properties so he was
the first one to write down that in fact
the way in which we affected the density
of things actually determines how they
appear to us in experiments so he
actually said that the stuff we call air
makes up everything that's the
fundamental constituent and earth and
water and fire just various versions of
how air appears depending on the
particular properties that it appears to
have on the basis of its density now
that's a wrong idea right but it got
people started and so Democritus and
lucifer's who I just mentioned before in
just a few years after this theory had
taken hold
said okay it's not air right everything
is not made of air we don't actually
know what it is but they abstracted the
idea to something that was very powerful
for us so what they did was to say if
you take anything no matter what it is
and you cut it in half and you take one
of those halves and you cut that in half
and you take that and you cut that in
half and you keep going on and on
they're the first ones to actually argue
that eventually you get to something
that can't be cut that in Greek is
called the atomos which we abstracts to
the atom and so they're the first person
the first people that we know to write
down a theory and influence others to
say that eventually everything has to be
made of something that is irreducible
it's as small as you can get and
everything else is built by putting
those pieces together in various ways
again following an axe amenties
observation that putting it together in
various ways could give it different
densities and different densities could
make it appear as though it was
different even though it's actually all
the same stuff so that idea is so
powerful that we've kept it as I said
for 2,500 years or so and that's called
the atomic theory now believe it or not
the atomic theory even though I said
we've kept it for 2,500 years it hasn't
always been invoke that is no one can
see an atom and consequently there were
many people who believed that they were
fictions right there are a nice idea
there are a way of thinking about how
you go about breaking things down to get
to the fundamental constituents so that
idea remained but the idea that atoms
themselves could actually have existence
was not so as recently as 1909 the chair
of chemistry at the University of
Chicago simply pronounced atoms of
fictions
right convenient but not really real and
so it's been only in the last century
that we've actually had the ability to
say we understand science well enough
that not only do we think that atoms are
a good idea we actually believe that in
fact everything is made of atoms but
what has changed in terms of the
original idea from Democritus is that
these atoms can appear in different
forms in other words not only in terms
of their density and how they're put
together but there isn't sort of one
kind of atom they're actually roughly
speaking in nature around 92 or so
different
of atoms and the way in which we
determine that has happened is by going
into this cutting experiment delighting
things in half and taking that and
dividing in half and taking that in
dividing in half and so what we wind is
I wind up doing is going through a chain
in which we take the smallest things
that we can see in a microscope like a
virus and if we put that into a
particular kind of experimental
apparatus that allows us to divide it or
to look at it in even more fine
resolution with things like x-rays as
opposed to visible light then we
eventually can see that it's made of
molecules and the molecules are made of
the things that we call atoms the atoms
are at the point of their discovery
around 1913 were the irreducible that is
people could not figure out a way to get
anything smaller than that however after
a few decades we were actually able to
not only theorize but then
experimentally discover and explain with
math that in fact the atom what we call
the atom we had pulled the trigger too
soon right that the atom in fact is not
irreducible it is made of still smaller
stuff the nucleus as I said was
discovered around 1913 then around 1918
or so it was understood that the nucleus
itself was made of something called
protons and neutrons and then the
protons and neutrons we discovered
around 1967 were made of still smaller
things that we call quarks but at that
point which is right now from around
1968 or so to now we think that quarks
and the things that surround the nucleus
called the electrons those are the
smallest irreducible elements of matter
we have not yet seen anything that's
smaller and we probably won't because
even though we might come up with more
powerful microscopes more powerful ways
of cutting things in half and try to
focus that on the court the quarks
themselves have been theorized and we
pretty much believe that the theory is
correct cannot ever be seen by
themselves that is we've actually now
gotten to the point where we think we're
firm
convinced that something exists which
can never itself be seen it can only be
seen in combinations with other things
and that means that we will never if
that theory is true be able to take a
single quark and divide it up that is a
problem only for philosophers right
physicists actually don't care because
again we can explain it in terms of
equations we can explain it in terms of
observations and we can explain it in
terms a simple language by just saying
what I just said that is there's no way
to take it even in principle and divide
it up into something that's still
smaller now of course anybody who makes
that pronouncement is on very shaky
ground physicists don't like making
predictions that we will never do
something or that something will always
be true nonetheless the best studies
that we have right now indicate that
that's true the math part of this comes
in the fact that we've been able to say
the courts themselves are and electrons
are what everything is built out of but
it's actually the atoms that is the the
functional part of an accident'
description of how things are
constructed to make the whole universe
which is to say we have this periodic
table of elements those are all the
different kinds of atoms that there are
now that in and of itself allows us to
do a tremendous amount of technology
right we can actually make all kinds of
things work and understand the
principles by how they work but
understanding nothing more than what's
in that table so everything beyond that
is only for the joy of the people who
like looking at hard problems and saying
is there anything more to be discovered
eventually there may be practical
concerns that come out of those kinds of
studies but those practical concerns are
not what directly drive us it's the way
that we get there that does along with
understanding what the fundamental
constituents are though we have to
understand what holds them together and
those are called the fundamental forces
fundamental because all kinds of forces
that you might think of like friction
right what makes it possible for me to
walk across the floor which would be
much more difficult if there were no
friction
or very little friction like ice all of
those forces can be made of or can be
seen as being just different
manifestations of one of the fundamental
forces and one that we're most familiar
with is electricity another one that
seems to mystify us or at least
mystified most people is magnetism but
there are other forces that we've
learned are fundamental that we can
actually manipulate for example nuclear
forces and so nuclear reactors are
simply manifestations of forces that
only operate on the on the on the
distance scale of nuclei or neutrons but
they can be turned into a practical way
of generating electricity and
electricity is the thing that sort of
drives our current society now there's
one other force which I'm gonna mention
which is called gravity but I'm going to
come back to that one gravity is the
most mysterious of the forces actually
even though it's the one that's probably
most familiar to everyday people because
it holds us to UM to the earth it keeps
things going down instead of letting
them go up for any length of time but
it's in fact the most mysterious to
understand and the rationale for that's
a little complicated but it has to do
with the fact that in order to
understand the equations for these guys
ultimately we have to depend on
something called quantum mechanics or
quantum quantum physics right and we
don't yet have a quantum physics theory
for gravity so even though we can
explain a lot about how it operates we
can't come up with an equation that
actually explains it its operations in
the same way that we can for the other
three forces so that's kind of a shame
it drives a lot of research that takes
place today including my research but
for reasons that I'll come back to a
little later now in and of itself the
picture has to be again once once again
abstracted and the reason is that
physicists don't like memorizing lots of
names of things and consequently the
periodic
we know that it exists and that's
probably good enough for us we can
identify most of the elements that we
see on it in terms of what their
chemical properties are but really we
have to understand how to get equations
to work and it's too complicated to do
it with the picture that we talked about
before so we abstracted by saying
there's two forms of existence
there's matter and there's energy which
holds the matter together or pushes it
apart and those two ideas are connected
by the most famous equation in all of
physics e equals MC squared and that
equation says nothing more than the fact
that energy and mass which is always
connected to matter as a property of
matter are tied together right one can
be converted into the other energy can
be made into matter and matter under
certain conditions can be made into
energy the reason why that's important
is that it basically says that the
fundamental picture again going all the
way back to Democritus and lucrative you
suppose is correct namely that if you
actually talk about matter rather than
all the different kinds of atoms and the
quarks and things that make it up then
in fact there is one picture that says
there is a fundamental stuff we just
call it matter as a generic name and
it's held together by something that's
called energy in various forms right for
different forms of it but those two are
connected by an equation that allows us
to explain properties of both so that
sort of seems as though we've gotten to
the end right we've actually explained
what we originally set out what is the
world made of well ultimately it's made
of quarks and electrons what holds it
together well the four fundamental
forces which are representatives forms
of energy and consequently we're all
done in which case I would not have a
job or at least half my job okay so that
makes me very sad so of course what I
have to do is to say well let me get
together with my colleagues and let's
actually question the assumption are we
actually done
did it all get finished decades ago and
the answer was for a lot of my career 25
years or so this was a very depressing
picture right it looked as though we'd
actually finished pretty much everything
that was of consequence and the really
deep questions had been answered there
are lots of ancillary questions with
science of course but the really deep
ones what is the world's made of what
holds it together had been answered now
of course I happen to live in a time
when that has happened that's a really
lucky thing for me but I didn't do a lot
of the work so obviously it's better for
me if the question is an answer and
they're still exciting questions to
suppose about what might have happened
so what that does for me is to say I
want to think about what questions we
would ask and how we would do those
three kinds of answers right the math
the observations and the simple language
the common-sense language for saying we
haven't finished this trail to the
fundamental constituents and luckily
enough for me it turns out that when we
ask those questions what's the future of
physics it turns out that in fact we are
not at the end not only are we not at
the end
we're not even clear that we're at the
beginning well let me explain why
so if we sort of say what's the future
of physics
most people think all right well we can
ask a question what's next well what's
next in this case is what is the next
experiment we would do what are the next
theories that we would write down the
math for and in their minds what they
have is again practical considerations
which is the future always involves
people being able to travel it anywhere
they want with self-driving cars or
living under the ocean or something
really exotic I would settle for just
being able to not have climate change
but that's probably not going to happen
at least in the next few years so the
question of what is the future the
future of physics is not tied to what
kinds of creations
we'll be able to come up with
technologically as I said most of the
observations that were made that led to
getting to the point of understanding
quarks and electrons and then this whole
equals mc-squared stuff had nothing to
do with people figuring out what are we
going to do to solve problems that
mankind or humankind is actually
interested in it was all about how do we
chase down whether or not we're at the
end of this 2500 year quest and so it
turns out that when we asked that
question it's the physics of invisible
stuff well invisible stuff that's right
that really doesn't sound like a very
satisfactory answer right but invisible
stuff is actually really important and
so I'm going to ask you a question which
everybody in this room will be able to
answer it's a physics question so I'm
going to assert that this whole room is
filled with something right now that is
invisible you can't hear it you can't
taste it you can't touch it really and
yet it's vitally important for us what
is it the air okay so what would happen
if I removed all the air in the room
well that might happen yes it's an old
building
probably the building would stay but the
rest of us would be God right so
invisible stuff that you can't see taste
touch or even really feel unless you're
moving your your hands very quickly is
vitally important so invisible stuff
does matter the problem with it is it's
invisible so it's really hard to make
observations on it however that's never
stopped physicists right what we do is
to simply say we have to define what
experiments we can do that would lead to
observations so air happens to be an
easy one because I can collect it and I
can put it into a container and I can
weigh this I can also do things that
demonstrate to me that I've done that
collection and that the collection has
been back released back into into the
general environment so it's actually
really possible to talk about
visible stuff in ways that we can
measure so we are not daunted as
scientists by saying it's invisible our
five senses find it really hard to
interact with it in a way that allows us
to do observations we just have to do
observations that are somewhat indirect
but there's a principle right it's not a
free-for-all game the thought has to be
that you must be able to weigh it you
must be able to collect it in order to
weigh it and you must be able to do
observations in the laboratory that are
reproducible when you do these kinds of
collections now that raises the bar
right but again degree of difficulty
just makes the game more fun so we're
not so concerned by the fact that it's
harder to do those things that just
means that we have to work a little
harder or to you know to actually be
honest we have to make the graduate
students work a little harder to get to
the point where we can actually make
observations that are reproducible but
based on these principles so if we talk
about seeing the invisible this is
really not so hard to do the laws of
physics are compelling but the laws of
physics are not just a phrase right
these are theories that we can test and
we test them over and over and over and
over again and as opposed to people who
think that anything that anybody comes
up with as an idea is a theory to become
a theory and in particular to become a
law of physics kind of theory you have
to constantly be willing to overthrow
that theory that is it takes only a
single observation to overthrow the
theory of evolution the fact that we
still have it means that no one has ever
come up with a operation for which it's
absolutely clear that the theory of
evolution makes the wrong prediction and
so we keep it because it makes sense of
millions of other observations that we
wouldn't have a way of connecting
together in any kind of intellectual
framework without it the same is true
for physics so at a certain point I
don't need to see direct experimental
evidence if I can do indirect results
that indicate that the theory is correct
that's actually good enough to have me
believe that in fact we've made progress
the progress in and of itself however
looks a little strange to people who
aren't used to dealing with this so for
example up here you see a cloud chamber
and the white thing that goes through
there is a radioactive source and so
this is nothing more than making the
invisible visible right there's
radiation that's coming off of the
source and what you see and the
streaking through the through the
chamber there whenever there's a little
puff of cloud that's a little light
that's a that's a subatomic particle
right one of the ones that I sort of
showed you in the chart earlier that's
being created and is being made visible
even though it's normally invisible what
you see up on the screen here is from my
demonstration lab back at Penn which is
exactly the same apparatus but it's
time-lapse so that what it shows you is
that radiation is constantly coming down
from the sky penetrating the room and us
going deep into the earth right so each
of those streaks that you see if there
is again something that's invisible
created outside of our earth and
streaming down from our atmosphere into
this room so invisible stuff is actually
all around us what we needed was to
develop experimental apparatus that made
it easier for us to see if you want to
go and see what the professionals do
this is something that you can actually
pull up on the internet as I said you
can get involved with this sitting at
your home in your slippers this is again
a time lapse because it doesn't actually
look this dangerous this would be really
bad if there were this much radiation
coming down on us but over several
minutes you can get screenshots from an
experiment in the north of Minnesota
that actually shows you cosmic rays or
cosmic radiation that's streaming down
into every area of the earth now the
fact that this invisible stuff exists
gives us no real information in saying
what the future is going to be per se
right there might be in some of these
observations something new that we
didn't expect but in fact this is not
the answer to the question
or at least a direction that we can see
says we're going to discover the next
fundamental stuff it might happen here
but probably not the most likely place
that it's going to happen so we have to
turn to something else and so this is
what happened to me when I went to
college at first I wanted to work with
the physics of the sky I wanted to be an
astrophysicist or a cosmologists and
like every beginning freshman what I did
was to find an advisor or at least I had
one assigned to me this advisor happened
to be an experimental astrophysicist and
I came in to him and I said I want to be
basically like you and he said no you
don't really we don't have the
technology right now to make this into a
real firm field if you want to be an
experimentalist what you should do is go
down the hall to the particle physicists
where there's something really really
interesting happening right now and you
can get involved right away
so that's what I did now it turns out
that part of a physicists are not all
that easy to work with right so when I
went in for my work-study job because I
was fully financial aid it as you just
heard from professors ill financial aid
actually goes back a very long way so if
you go to a competitive college my
parents couldn't afford even a single
dollar to send my room and board or
tuition for college but Northwestern
University provided absolutely
everything I needed but I had to do a
work-study job in order to earn enough
money to eat okay
the first work-study jobs that are
offered are course in the library
stacking books the next ones are in the
food halls you know stacking dishes none
of that sounded very interesting so out
of the entire list of 450 of those the
one that looked most interesting was the
one that was in the physics department
there was precisely one position open
and it was in particle physics so advice
from an astrophysicist go to the
particle physicists an opportunity to
work for particle physics kismet that's
what I have to do so I went and I
thought it's a shoo-in right who wants
to work in physics No
but he will want that job I was the 13th
in line the last one and the interview
lasted roughly 35 38 seconds it
consisted of just a few questions
have you ever programmed the computer do
you know how to solder can you build
electronics can you design electronic
circuit boards no no no no no I'll call
you literally what he said to me and so
I left with my tail between my legs
really dejected how could I be a failure
as a physicist in my first week in
college already deemed not good enough
however if you edit if you understand
anything about where I grew up is e st.
Louis right thought it was part of the
great great migration everybody who
really didn't have enough money to make
it to Chicago from Mississippi stopped
in East st. Louis of st. Louis and so my
family stopped half of them in he say it
was the other half in Chicago and so
it's really just Mississippi moved 300
miles north right it has southern
sensibilities so I was really dejected I
was really sad but I also thought you
shouldn't say something that you don't
mean right so he shouldn't have said
I'll call you if he never meant to
actually call so it took every bit of
courage I had to actually go back and
force him to tell me I wasn't good
enough to be a work-study student in the
particle physics laboratory I knocked on
the door I stuck in my head and what do
you think he said he said I guess you're
ready to get started and I said no you
said you would call and he said there
are things that I can teach and there
are things that I can't teach everybody
who comes in that door I asked him the
same set of questions and the answer is
always no to all of them your freshman
right of course you don't know how to do
any of that stuff but all of that stuff
I can teach but what I do is to tell
everybody I'll call them and I hire the
first person who comes back
now that's a lesson in physics I didn't
understand the lesson at the time
because you can imagine what I'm
thinking right this dude is crazy I
don't know anything more than I did last
week why you hiring me now and so he put
me to work
learning how to solder on old circuit
boards teaching me all about electronics
and how to use an oscilloscope and then
roughly a week later Ayer professor the
senior professor on the project building
experiments at Fermilab came in and said
and I have to give you the whole picture
right it's a little bit funny all it
takes us a little off topic right he's
about six six and he had a goatee and he
really looked like the devil smoking a
big stogie because even in those days
you weren't allowed to smoke in the
building but nobody was gonna tell him
that okay he comes in and he yells out
in a booming voice I hear we got fresh
meat where is he that was me come with
me so I follow him to the deepest
dankest part of the basement of a
physics building which happened to be
the loading dock and it was a room that
was filled floor to ceiling with 20-foot
steel beams and bales of gold-plated
copper wire and he said I'm building an
experiment that starts up in 18 months
at Fermilab and I need you to make me 24
planer drift chambers and of course my
jaw dropped I had no idea what a planar
drift chamber is let alone how you build
one which of course he knew and so what
was his reaction he clapped me on the
back and said some assembly required and
he left at that point I kind of realized
what the first lesson was about right
only somebody's stupid enough to keep
coming back is actually going to make it
through this group but I did keep coming
back eventually I did produce all the
electronics all of the boards and all of
the plaintiff drift chambers in two
years not 18 months and I realized that
I could be a particle physicist now the
whole point of that story is to say that
all of that technology that I was
supposed to learn how to develop was
based on the idea that nobody knows how
to do this stuff
we have to figure it out as we go along
and so when I decided to go back into
astrophysics after 20 years as a
particle physicist it was around the
idea that we had learned something about
the technology necessary to make
advancements on these two fundamentals
have we found all the fundamental stuff
in the universe and that was on the
basis of the fact that it had to be
invisible so we needed the right
technology in order to make it visible
so what was that technology well it
turns out that Einstein had predicted it
really back around 1916 which is to say
that he gave us in 1915 of theory then
he expanded on in 1916 of gravity which
was completely different than the theory
of gravity from Newton and this theory
actually does make it possible to
indirectly see stuff that is invisible
the way it works is gravity itself bends
the path of anything that's moving and
so this is a real picture from NASA of
again it's a time-lapse photograph of a
star passing in front of another star
which happens all the time but you'll
see that the yellow star the yellow dot
seems to be moving of course that's not
really happening right stars are pretty
massive and the distance between the
blue and the yellow is actually really
large so what you actually see is the
light from the yellow star being bent by
the gravity of the blue so if we put a
grid up there we can actually see that
the light is being distorted and what
that means is that you've got a
different picture of how the universe
works and how you can find out what's
actually in it because now at this point
if we understand that even invisible
stuff has gravity then we can see the
effects of its gravity even if we can't
see the stuff itself so now even if
you're invisible or as astronomers call
it dark then we can actually know that
there's other stuff in the universe even
if we haven't found it in our
laboratories we haven't figured out how
to weigh it we haven't figured out how
to gather some of it here and make
measurements on it
have a little bit less here okay and
when we did that or I should say when
astronomers did that what we saw was a
really surprising picture which is that
the atoms the stuff that we spent all
the centuries trying to find and then in
the last century actually figured out
how to characterize and observe and see
that we get down to quarks all that
stuff all that effort none of that was
wasted
it was just not very useful because all
of that stuff all the stuff that makes
up you and everything in the room is
actually responsible for only 5% of the
gravity that's actually out there which
means that most of the stuff in the
universe 95% of the total mass energy as
we call it is actually invisible stuff
which was a pretty shocking thing to
discover 22 years ago 21 years ago I
guess but in fact it's really true we
see evidence of gravity distorting
things like this isn't gravity it should
be a nice spiral it's distorted that way
not because of the shape of the galaxy
itself but because the light has been
distorted by all the gravity of the
invisible stuff that's between us and
that observation so this makes the
mission in life for the next phase the
future of physics of invisible stuff
really really clear we might be able to
reproduce it in the laboratory by having
particle colliders put a lot of energy
into a very small volume and maybe
there's some hope that that will happen
but even if it doesn't happen we will
still be able to do experiments on the
invisible stuff by looking at what
effects it has had on the universe over
time the universe itself is a laboratory
and it's a dynamic laboratory it changes
it gets small it gets larger and larger
over time and the rate at which it gets
larger and larger over time is actually
dependent on all of the stuff all those
fundamentals constituents whether we can
see them or not their gravity is still
there
and by observing the effects of gravity
we can say something about the
fundamental constituents and also before
the energy that's holding them together
so this is called the large survey large
synoptic survey telescope this is my
next project is being built right now on
a high mountain top around in a little
place called la Cerreta Chile but it's
not so important where it is except that
it's really high and very dry and it's
basically a big camera it's a camera
that's very similar in many ways to this
one except that this one has depending
on what version of it you have between
eight and twelve million pixels this one
has more than three billion
it's the largest telescope camera that's
ever been devised and the fact that it
exists is not so important because
that's technology but the technology is
being put to use for something that has
never before been accomplished or even
attempted which is to say the point of
having a synoptic survey telescope is
not to have people look through it at a
particular target on the sky that's what
the Hubble Space Telescope does
basically this one is made to simply
take pictures of the sky every night and
every three nights it sees everything in
the half of the southern half of the sky
that we can see from South America and
it keeps a record in its pictures of
everything that changes night tonight
tonight so why is that important well
first we've never understood what's
called the dynamic universe when we take
a picture it's like any picture it's a
snapshot so when you see a photograph or
a portrait on the walls in this building
you're getting a snapshot of that person
as they existed at the time when the
portrait or picture was made but it
would be better if you wanted to
understand the person if you had a
series of pictures that showed them
growing up from baby to adult to retiree
right
and the question of how we do this for
the universe is answered here and that's
because the further out we look with the
telescope the further back in time we
look so we can see how not only the
universe but everything that's visible
in the universe has been developing from
roughly 13 billion years ago to just a
billion or so years ago but we can also
see everything that's happening inside
of our own solar system so this is a
record if you want it's a movie at very
high resolution very high definition of
everything that takes place in the
universe that changes over time
over the 10-year period for which this
camera will be taking continual pictures
night after night after night and from
that we will discover many new things
that we never saw before that we didn't
know existed that are visible but more
important for people like me is that by
looking at the form of gravity and how
it behaves over time we will understand
those invisible fates that I talked
about that make up 95% of the mass of
the universe now we give them generic
names we call them dark matter and dark
energy but those really are generic
names and so I don't try to describe
them because in fact we don't know what
they are really and so I can't give you
either equations and I certainly can't
give you a common-sense language
understanding of what they are and at
the moment I could give you some
observations but those observations we
understand are not yet complete enough
to answer the first or the third type of
explanation that I that I mentioned
earlier and so I don't really feel it's
important to try and understand how I
would say to you what is dark matter or
what is dark energy because in fact it
could be anything at this point we don't
actually know anything other than its
existence how much of it is there is and
we know a little bit about its
properties right dark energy this room
is filled with it dark matter this room
is filled with it right every little
space that's about like that has one of
these dark matter particles streaming
through it right now so through your
body every second there are billions of
particles called neutrinos coming from
the Sun there are thousands
these little dark matter particles
streaming through you have been for
everybody since the existence of
humankind and we never knew it until
just a few years ago however the fact
that we know that yeah it doesn't make
you uncomfortable probably right
dark matter is there but it doesn't seem
to have much effect on you otherwise we
probably would have discovered that it
existed a long time ago so what we need
to do as I said is to keep a record of
what its effect has been on the universe
as a whole in order to actually
understand what it does or how it how
its properties actually impact the
universe and so this camera will do that
by making a catalog as I said of
everything that's changed how the
universe has evolved but there's also
other kinds of science that you can do
if you're interested in pure astronomy
like you want to know exoplanets right
where they exist this will be powerful
enough to see the planets but it can
actually do follow-up observations of
the solar systems in which those planets
occur if you want to know is there a
killer asteroid that's maybe 50 meters
across scheduled to hit the earth 50
years from now this telescope will see
it if you want to know are there
supernovas that are exploit exploding
stars that are occurring night after
night after night well the answer most
likely is certainly yes but if you want
to know exactly where they are what
what's that star before it exploded how
did it look we've never accepted a few
very very few cases been able to say
this is what the star looked like before
it exploded so we can say something
about what actual characteristics that
had before in order to come to the point
where it makes an explosion so for the
first time we'll have all of this record
in the database and as I said citizen
science is one of the things that's a
focus for this so you will actually be
able to see all of this information
because it will all be freely available
and online so working with companies
like Google that makes Google Earth
there will be a Google universe that
actually shows you just as much
information as you can get from Google
Earth but through the data set of these
pictures but what we want to know
specifically is how the universe went
from a hot
chaotic state which was very clear
happened around 13.7 billion years ago
to something that looks much more
ordered much more sensible and is a lot
cooler right 13 billion years sounds
like a long time but in point of fact
that time is really precisely described
by general relativity in terms of again
the stuff that makes up the universe if
we didn't have dark matter and dark
energy why would I say that they're
important well because if we didn't have
them we wouldn't be here almost
certainly if you don't have exactly the
right amount of gravity coming from dark
matter and dark energy
then the universe either evolves too
quickly or too slowly what is too
quickly mean well too quickly
eventually if dark energy continues to
do what it's doing today the entire
universe will blow up and what I mean by
blow up is not an explosion it just
means that the universe is expanding and
the rate at which it expands is
increasing so at some point it would be
possible that the distance between my
eye and my hand is increasing even
though I'm not moving because space
between my eye in my hand is increasing
and at some point that can be any speed
at once faster than light so it actually
will be the case someday if we don't
actually understand what the properties
of dark energy are over billions of
years it could be the case that the
universe actually just expands into
nothingness basically becomes so thin
that in fact even atoms are separated
from each other there's no existence at
least in terms of what we think now if
dark energy had been much larger in the
past that could have occurred before we
had solar systems or people in order to
study the question on the other hand if
we didn't have dark matter then dark
matters gravity makes it possible for
things to coalesce together to get this
picture of galaxies that you see here
let's call the Hubble ultra-deep field
so that is also disastrous because it
means that things don't develop enough
for there to actually be planets to hold
together and again you don't get life or
at least you don't get us and you
don't get intelligence in order to study
the question it turns out that for the
amount of dark matter and dark energy
that we have this is 95 percent being in
that form and 5 percent in the form of
everything else that we looked at over
the last few centuries it happens to be
just the right amount so that 13.7
billion years is just enough time to get
to the kind of universe that we see here
so that sort of looks like either a
really lucky coincidence
or that there's something fundamental
and dark matter and dark energy that had
to be the way it is in order to make
this possible now the fact that we can
do this as I said does depend on
technology one of that one of that
aspect of that technology is that we can
actually deliver the tremendous data
that takes this will be the biggest data
source in all of science during the time
that its operating for 10 years and
that's really huge right the only data
sets that will be larger than this once
we talk about the simulations that go
along with it are the ones for your
credit card companies ok it's true story
right and so handling all that data
means that we need to change the way
that we educate students computers are
much more important those students will
be doing the same kinds of things they
do now in terms of science but they'll
have to do it very differently they'll
have to learn how to apply statistics in
very different ways and they'll have to
use what's called data science in order
to figure out how to reduce this but you
can help one of the ways that you help
is that you drive some of the questions
that are of interest which is that an
important aspect as I said is that this
database will all be available online
but in order to make use of it in order
to justify the government spending money
to figure out how to make people able to
use it most effectively and efficiently
for example you should never have an
astronomy class that needs an actual
telescope again
that sounds bad right I'm you know sort
of like the biology lab that has nothing
living in it but in fact this telescope
can see everything that's in the
southern hemisphere of the sky all the
time so you can have a database any time
of the day or night that actually tells
you what's in the sky anything that you
want to study about it is actually a
veil
there and so education should be a
profoundly impacted by having the
existence of so much of that and so
citizen science is one of the things
that we concentrate on classroom
research how to make most effective use
of this is one of the things that you
know it's not me but people like me will
be looking at that discovery
opportunities the citizens can get
involved with will be a an important
part of the study that we will have
graduate students and other physicists
and astrophysicists actually looking at
now the fact is that this doesn't come
without problems of some type right
first of all this is a very very
expensive kind of instrument in terms of
the things that we normally think of as
being expensive but even still this is
around a billion dollars right to build
and it's around fifty fifty five million
dollars a year to operate and so being
astronomers we have to actually raise
that money right we simply can't ask the
government for it so one of the other
things that changes with this is that we
have to figure out how to have private
philanthropy fund part of the research
now I understand that you've probably
seen that there are private philanthropy
efforts for some kinds of science
research that is being done but nothing
that's this concentrated for this we
will need to figure out how to raise
millions of dollars per year in order to
make the data that's coming from the
billion that's already been spent more
useful and especially for citizens doing
science so hopefully you can expect to
see more than that coming up now that
means that I have to leave you with an
unfortunate endpoint so I won't bring up
the last slide it's too depressing
which is I've got no ultimate answers
right dark matter and dark energy as I
said those are probably the end points
but we don't know for sure because we
don't know enough about what they are so
I have to end by saying that's actually
a really positive thing right so if
you're 12 years old right now and just
discovering physics you've actually
probably got a good 10 years before we
actually know anything very effectively
about what dark energy is or dark matter
for that
we might get lucky but most likely it
will still be an existing problem and if
there's anything that's beyond that it
will actually be on the back of an
experiment like this that we discovered
the ways in which we will actually make
the next advances that go to the next
phase of answering those two questions
but it's incredibly lucky that we live
in a time where stuff that we didn't
know about for centuries we've actually
all of a sudden got the opportunity to
study to actually observe and to make it
all possible to bring it into the home
of essentially everybody on earth that
has an internet connection which i think
is a pretty cool thing so thanks very
much for your time
[Applause]
now
shadows are just exactly what they
appear to be right that they block light
that's coming around
you know everything and surround the
object so they have an existence but the
existence again is an indirect ones
right you know that the light exists and
you know that the thing that creates the
shadow exists question here so in a few
minutes we're gonna have a raffle if you
want to hang around for that if you need
to leave to do so quietly before we get
around to the raffle question here yes
13.7 yes no okay so the question is I
said that the universe has a finite life
13.7 billion years ago and the question
comes up what happened before that so
that's another hour-long discussion but
basically space and time are created
along with the universe so there's
nothing before that because there's no
space there's no time there's nothing
you can say in terms of you know what
there was because there wasn't anything
I you know not a hundred percent but I
would say like 99 percent yes how do I
know if the dark matter dark energy very
good question
dark matter in principle we don't know
that it's different than dark entities
so there are some people who actually do
theorizes a connection between the two
but in principle we think dark matter is
eventually something that we will be
able to collect and way dark energy does
not seem to have the property that it's
actually collectible that we can have a
little bit more of it here and a little
bit less of it there so it's most likely
that we will never be able to do those
kind of direct experiments and that's
why we distinguish the two of them
what makes us sure that it's expanding
well there's there's actually lots of
lines of evidence the most direct one is
that if light is coming from a distant
object what we see is that the light
itself produces is in the form of a
spectrum right each of the atoms has an
independent fingerprint if you will of
the light that it admits what it's
excited and that light is shifted in
terms of its its wavelength or frequency
in comparison to the light from the same
atoms on earth and we asked why would
that happen well the easiest way to
explain why that happens is that the
object is moving so if you're standing
near a roadway and you hear a police
siren or a ambulance siren you notice
that the pitch changes right it gets
higher as it's coming towards you and it
goes lower as it goes past you and so
that's called the Doppler effect it
happens for anything that has waves that
travels in waves light does that and so
what we think is the frequency shift
seems to correspond to objects being
further away from us moving and the
further away they are the faster they
seem to be moving which would be exactly
what you would expect if something is
expanding right because if you sort of
think about it things that are close to
you expand very slowly things that are
away from you for the same expansion
rate have to be going faster
mm-hmm constituents yes
the virus okay so the virus is is
roughly less than 1/100 of the thickness
of your hair okay so really small what
happens when they what well
unfortunately we probably would have
seen them before if they actually
interact it they don't appear to
actually interact at all dark matter as
far as we know has only really really
really weak interactions with anything
and dark energy seems to affect things
only through its gravity it doesn't seem
to have any ability to change by force
interactions with anything else and so
it has gravity which does the effect but
nothing else
that's a good question and so if you
were throwing darts at a dartboard right
eventually if you're really good you
discover the size of the target the
little red dot at the beginning by
virtue of being very good at reproducing
the throwing of the darts and you can
see when it hits the center and you can
see when it hits around the outside edge
so that gives you eventually some idea
of what the size is if you're able to
consistently throw the dart in such a
way that you can see where it misses and
where hits and bounces back so we
actually you know take that and turn it
into math equations which are quite a
bit more sophisticated than what I just
said but it's essentially the same thing
all right so we can see the size of the
protons by actually colliding things
with the proton and the way in which
they bounce off tells us something about
the characteristic size of what the
target is assuming that we know the beam
that we're throwing at it very
accurately yes
yes yeah that's a really good question
so the answer is you you have to sort of
just if you have to you have to define
what you mean by important right and so
in terms of the ability for solar
systems to form probably not at that
scale but in terms of having large-scale
structure that we sort of see in the
behavior of the universe in terms of
what we look at patterns that we see
galaxies forming it's important in terms
of the science because it tells us
something about again general relativity
gives us a road map but in order to
define the road map really well we need
scales characteristic scales a map is no
good to you unless you know where mile
you know what the length of a mile is on
it and so these characteristic large
scale structures that we sort of see is
one of the ways that we kind of tell
what the scale of the universe is and
how it's changed over time so dark
matter affects that and dark energy does
as well so one of the ways we tell the
properties of those is we see how that
has been changing over time so it's
important scientifically but in terms of
you know philosophy do we need do we
need that in order to form solar systems
or planets probably not
yes
well as I said that's a problem right so
we are we will be well past the point
with this telescope of having human eyes
see all of the pictures so we will have
to use computers to do that force which
means that we have to figure out how to
teach the computers to actually detect
patterns and tell us new things that we
didn't expect to see in those pictures
so computers have to become smart they
have to become intelligent
well in fact in my field at particle
physics we've actually figured out how
to do that we think pretty well which is
there's a certain level in which you can
train computers to follow aspects of
what's called machine learning which is
they can learn the patterns that we feed
them very well and then they can
identify anything that looks like a
pattern that's not one of the patterns
that we've trained it on so there are
techniques that actually work pretty
well for doing that that we've tested
that they have to get even better for
handling the data we're talking about
here right now join me in thanking
professor Gladney
[Applause]
[Music]